on our travels through selfie world
today rocky is teaching us about an
interactive photography
studio more than just the perfect
instagramable spot
it's got a great story she says in time
for women's history month hey again
rocky
hey kirsten yeah guys it's time to get
in our feelings a little bit okay
because this is an actual
positive pandemic story and i can't wait
to introduce
well lexa to you but she's gonna tell
you about the owner okay
so alexa is the social media manager of
selfie world so uh you are busy
yes for sure we've been keeping up with
social media and marketing lately since
we've got out here
my cousin ashley wilkerson is the ceo
she's from iowa so she started selfie
world last summer
she had been a photographer for 11 years
she has two kids
and then a few years ago she had cancer
she's in reminition now so she's doing
well
and then she had to sell her house once
covet hit and had to move out
and try to figure out what to do next
with her life so she came up with the
idea of selfie world
so she started it that summer in iowa
tick tock blew
up and then everybody started to want to
franchise around
so then my parents want to franchise so
people can own them in different places
yes definitely so there's about 40
that'll be coming now and we're the
sixth franchise in the united states
that's amazing and i hear we're the
largest
yes we have 22 booths so we have the
most boots around in square feet
that is incredible so when people come
down how do they do it do they make a
reservation what's it like
yeah so we take walk-ins or you can make
a reservation online through our website
and then they purchase tickets for an
hour and then they get a walk around
with a ring light for an hour and kind
of do yourself photography
that is so dope and you guys also just
added the new light or the new
multi-colored ring light so this is you
get some pretty advanced technology here
yeah for sure it's super fun it's easy
to learn though and once you catch on to
it you just walk around and have fun
yeah i'm definitely a fan and could be
here all day okay
so these are our girls if you saw them
earlier in the show we've got marissa
the photographer we got kaylee our
beautiful model they are also cousins
fyi
and what i want to show you is she did
an outfit change
she's done about three since we got here
okay and that's one of the beauties of
selfie world 2 this is actually
an old banana republic so there are
fitting rooms in the back
you guys thought of it all yeah that was
definitely one of our best features we
want everybody to know that they can
express themselves and be
themselves and just show self-love with
their selfies selfie love
selfie love is the best love
we talk about how we're one of the
happiest places in las vegas so
we love it here that's beautiful and how
do people do it safely just really quick
uh
yeah so you have to wear a mask when
you're walking around we have hand
sanitizer everywhere
and we also wipe down everything
beautiful so come on down you guys to
selfie world i love it here
i'm gonna go take a few pictures learn
it from the from the pros
send it back to you more like a few
hundred pictures i'm sure rocky
yeah that place is great for my 24 year
old she would love it